here we are
Riley Keough making her Tick-Tock debut
Tick Tock
we're so happy to be on Tick Tock here
we are the actress is all smiles
alongside her Daisy Jones and the six
co-stars Sam Claflin in their first
appearances on the app hey Tick Tock hey
tick tock
we made it
finally
on Tick Tock it's a talk take
out Riley appearing in good spirits one
month after Mom Lisa Marie Presley's
death
so why did the actors join Tick Tock
well it might have taken a little
convincing from their friend
yep the two jumped on the bandwagon all
thanks to another Daisy Jones castmate
Suki Waterhouse
a wonderful exciting new
um
gift
for our upcoming show Daisy Jones and
the six very well done
that gift the new trailer for their
highly anticipated series which dropped
Wednesday can I ask you a question
what do you think the song's about what
do I think the song is about what the
song what do I think the song that I
wrote is about
it's about starting a new life
I don't know who I am it's about
dreaming of something different plus
eager fans can catch a bit of the show's
original songs too
[Music]
[Applause]
your first single and it hits number one
how do you top that
Riley joined the acting World in 2010.
it's what everybody says you know it's
the Art's worth it you know like
whatever happens happens so but as she
told ET a few years back she had
different plans for her career
originally I'd wanted to be a director I
never really wanted to act and then it
sort of started changing as I got older
but I still
primarily want to direct and so
hopefully that that'll happen whether
it's directing acting or Tick Tock we
can't wait to see what's next from her
[Music]